wer wann und wo gesundheitsminister
spahn regel per verordnung wie die groko
na impfungen nach weihnachten starten
soll
deutschlands hotspot nummer eins das
infektionsrisiko dominiert den alltag in
sachsen jeden tag mehr und schalkes
retter in der not huub stevens wird zum
vierten mal trainer und soll die
mannschaft aus dem tabellenkeller führen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und haben allen an
diesem freitag heute um 7 auch heute
natürlich mit dem sport und mit norbert
könig genannt
wenn der korona impfstoff zugelassen und
einsatzbereit ist in deutschland und das
soll ja bereits ab 27
dezember der fall sein wer bekommt ihn
dann zuerst diese frage beantwortet die
impfverordnung die
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen
heute unterzeichnet hat höchste
priorität haben über 80 jährige sowie
menschen in heimen und krankenhäusern
wir beginnen unsere berichterstattung
heute abend mit pablo seal allawi und
den regeln im detail geimpft werden soll
in mehreren stufen zuallererst sind
menschen über 80 jahre und pflegeheim
bewohner an der reihe
auch medizinisches personal mit sehr
hohem ansteckungsrisiko gehört dazu etwa
in notaufnahmen und solche mit engem
kontakt zu cupid von zehn infizierten
zur stufe zwei zellen ältere zwischen 70
und 79 jahren menschen mit demenz oder
einer geistigen behinderung die in
einrichtungen leben auch die hausärzte
gehören dazu und enge kontaktpersonen
von pflegebedürftigen und schwangeren
zur stufe 3 gehören personen ab 60
jahren und solche mit erhöhtem risiko
für einen schweren verlauf einer corona
infektion auch mitarbeiter besonders
relevanter berufe zählen dazu zum
beispiel polizei feuerwehr und erzieher
zuletzt kommen alle anderen menschen
unter 60 jahren und ohne vorerkrankungen
an die reihe
diese impfverordnung ist das eine die
praktische umsetzung das andere und da
gibt es noch viele hürden und auch viele
fragen dazu kommt generelle kritik an
der prioritätenliste mehr dazu von lars
bohnsack
der gesundheitsminister ahnte wohl dass
seine prioritätenliste nicht bei jedem
auf verständnis trifft und so geht s
jens spahn erst einmal darum diejenigen
zu beruhigen
die nicht ganz oben auf der liste stehen
deswegen bitte ich alle anderen
bürgerinnen und bürger um geduld
ich bitte sie darum abzuwarten bis auch
sie an der reihe sind wir beginnen
zuerst mit den älteren den hochbetagten
denjenigen die sie pflegen und betreuen
und genau diese besonders verwundbaren
zu schützen
der bund besorgt zwar den impfstoff die
länder aber müssen die verteilung
organisieren und die impfung vor ort
hier in hamburg sieht man sich gut
gewappnet
wir sind bereit die abläufe sind geprobt
und geklärt sie werden sie nachher noch
sehen was uns noch fehlt ist der
endstufe kritik kommt von
patientenschützern sparpläne ignorierten
dass die meisten menschen nicht in
heimen sondern zu hause gepflegt würden
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat uns
gesagt die schwächsten zuerst das ist
richtig aber warum vergisst dann die
pflegenden angehörigen die müssen ebenso
wie die altenpflegekräfte in die stufe 1
die opposition steht grundsätzlich
hinter den massnahmen fordert aber dass
der bundestag darüber abstimmen soll
weil auch staatsrechtler ja empfohlen
haben dass wenn der staat in grundrechte
eingreift das sehr klar gelenkt werden
muss sind eine demokratie und solch
grundlegende sachen sollten im bundestag
beschlossen werden
am 27 dezember sollen die impfungen
losgehen abzusehen ist dass die
diskussionen über die reihenfolge da
noch mal an fahrt gewinnen
wie fehr ist die im freien folge darum
geht es bei zdf heute live mit einem
medizinethiker und auch sie können
mitdiskutieren um 19 30 auf zdf heute.de
und in unserer app und so sieht die
aktuelle corona situation bei uns heute
aus das robert koch institut meldet
insgesamt 33 1777 positiv ausgefallene
tests
das sind mehr als heute vor einer woche
allerdings wurden rund 3500
infektionsfälle aus baden württemberg
von gestern nachgemeldet 800 13 weitere
menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
virus gestorben
immer wieder und immer noch besonders
gefährdet sind die alten und pflegeheime
in pritzwalk in brandenburg zum beispiel
haben sich mehr als 100 heimbewohner
infiziert in marburg in hessen wurden 39
von 41 bewohnern eines pflegeheims
positiv getestet das gesamte personal
ist krankgeschrieben oder in quarantäne
wie die belegschaft in einem pflegeheim
in bramsche in niedersachsen mit der
krise umgeht zeigt jetzt elisabeth
schmidt jeder besucher muss einen
schnelltest machen bevor er ins
seniorenzentrum der arbeiterwohlfahrt
dem niedersächsischen bramsche
hineinkommt auch unser kamerateam für
die mitarbeiter bedeutet dass 25 stunden
zusätzliche arbeit pro woche
allerdings muss ich leider auch sagen
dass wir ganz oft in situationen kommen
wo wir uns rechtfertigen müssen wo wir
beschimpft werden wo wir uns mit
anzeigen gedroht wird besucher die es
für reine schikane halten wenn sie das
pflegeheim nicht betreten dürfen sobald
es dort einen corona verdachtsfall gibt
mehrere besucher gehabt die sich durch
personal eingänge und lieferanten
eingänge geschmuggelt haben wir haben
uns schon wie ein pitbull teilweise hier
vor die einrichtung stellen müssen
zwei mitarbeiter haben sich bislang mit
dem corona virus infiziert die bewohner
blieben gesund die psychische belastung
ist enorm sagt der einrichtungsleiter in
einem youtube video bilder zeigen
pflegekräfte sind superhelden sie wollen
jeden tag ihr bestes geben
die arbeit mit liebe beruf ich könnte es
nicht gute laune und gute planung das
zählt für das seniorenheim in diesen
zeiten mit masken und schnelltests haben
sie hier bis märz schon mal vorgesorgt
in brandenburg werden an manchen orten
die krankenhausbetten knapp mehr als 60
patienten wurden deshalb heute nach
berlin und sachsen-anhalt verlegt um in
krankenhäusern dort weiter versorgt zu
werden
die kliniken in brandenburg wollen so
verhindern dass es zu einem engpass
kommt in den nächsten tagen rechnen sie
mit weiter steigenden patientenzahlen
und auch sachsen hat die pandemie fest
im griff
19 sächsische städte und gemeinden
liegen mittlerweile über der grenze von
1000 infektionen pro pro 100000
einwohner in einer woche viele
krankenhäuser sind überfüllt und deshalb
geht auch die diskussion weiter ob orte
in denen das virus besonders wütet von
der polizei abgeriegelt werden sollten
aus dresden stefan kelch wenn statistik
und wirklichkeit zusammenprallen
entsteht zuweilen schwer erklärbare es
etwa ein incidents wert von über 2900 in
der gemeinde cap schütz teil bei meisten
der landesweit höchste incidents wert
dem bürgermeister nicht nur ein
mathematisches rätsel
es ist unheimlich schwer weil ich vom
gesundheitsamt keine dort bekommen wo
ist der hotspot ich gehe davon aus dass
das über die familien ihre brauchen wird
weil wir am keine disco wir haben keine
gaststätten wir haben gar nichts wir
haben die vereinshäuser geschlossen
ich denke man hat das ja viele bürger in
städten arbeiten und den virus einfach
mit einschleppen
solche gemeinden abriegeln das wird
diskutiert seine wäre dann wohl eine der
ersten solche planspiele machen den
bürgermeister zornig
wir werden auf keinen fall schilder
aufstellen wo draufsteht achtung solche
bitte sprechen sie mit meinem bürgern
gehören 37 ortsteile haben die
bundesstraße
ich wüsste nicht wie ich das klären
sollte derzeit betont die
landesregierung dass sie keine
abregelung plant jedenfalls noch nicht
als momentaner sicht nicht das haben wir
gestern ganz klar geäußert aber meine
aufmerksamkeit ist wirklich dass wir von
kommunaler ebene angefangen bis zur
landesregierung an wirklich alle die
verantwortung wahrnehmen verantwortung
nimmt nun auch die landesärztekammer war
sie sagt kroner leugnen in der
ärzteschaft den kampf an
diese internistin aus dem erzgebirge
reist durch sachsen ausgestattet mit dem
vertrauensvorschuss des berufsstandes
die maske vergleich mit dem judenstern
und behauptet das maß getragen krank
mache jetzt stellt ihr landesärztekammer
strafanzeige gegen sie will ihr die
approbation entziehen
steigen wir immer mehr corona fälle auch
auf den kanaren die bundesregierung
stufte deshalb die inseln erneut als
risikogebiet 1
ab sonntag gilt eine reisewarnung dann
wieder für ganz spanien
reiserückkehrer müssen in quarantäne
auch in österreich bleibt die lage
angespannt die regierung hat jetzt einen
dritten lockdown beschlossen ab dem 26
dezember bis mindestens mitte januar
gelten wie der ausgangs beschränkungen
auch tagsüber auch die geschäfte die vor
weihnachten öffnen durften müssen wieder
schließen
die impfstoffe gegen korona für alle
menschen auf der welt zugänglich und
bezahlbar machen das sei jetzt die große
herausforderung sagte
uno-generalsekretär antonio guterres
heute im bundestag
anlass für den besuch vor 75 jahren
wurden die vereinten nationen gegründet
guterres lobte deutschlands
internationales engagement nicht nur in
der korona krise deutschland sei eine
friedensmacht die verantwortung und
tiefes geschichtsbewusstsein zeige die
us regierung ist ziel eines massiven
hackerangriffs die behörde für cyber
sicherheit warnt das entfernen der
schadware sei extrem schwierig
washington post und new york times hatte
berichtet bei den angreifern handele es
sich um hacker mit verbindungen zum
russischen
dienst die regierung in moskau hat das
zurückgewiesen dass washington berichtet
jetzt peter theißen hier waren sie drin
im netz des finanzministeriums der usa
die hacker schafften es sogar ins
energieministerium das für die
sicherheit des atomwaffenarsenals
wichtig ist die us cyber
sicherheitsbehörde sieht eine ernste
gefahr für die kritische infrastruktur
und verdächtigt russischer hacker hinter
dem angriff der offenbar schon vor einem
halben jahr begann man versucht immer
die zeit zwischen dem angriff und der
entdeckung zu reduzieren im idealfall
auf minuten oder stunden aber hier waren
es nicht tage sondern mehrere monate das
bedeutet dass die russen die wohl
dahinter stecken richtig viel zeit
hatten sich im system umzusehen
microsoft arbeitet an der aufklärung mit
dort heißt es das sei keine übliche
spionage gewesen die attacke habe eine
ernste technische schwachstelle für die
usa und die welt geschaffen die
möglicherweise noch andauert dennoch gab
es von präsident trump keine reaktion
anders der designierte präsident joe
biden
ich werde selber sicherheit zur höchsten
priorität auf allen ebenen meiner
regierung machen dazu werde ich hart
gegen die angreifer vorgehen
die attacke erfolgte über eine weit
verbreitete software
der schaden ist noch nicht absehbar
gross ist dabei jedem fall der image
verlust für die vereinigten staaten die
supermacht steht blamiert da im
innersten getroffen
zurück nach deutschland in der
fleischindustrie gelten künftig
strengere vorschriften
das hat heute der bundesrat beschlossen
um ausbeutung und riskante
arbeitsbedingungen zu verhindern ist ab
januar der einsatz von subunternehmern
mit osteuropäischen billiglöhnern
verboten
es soll keine werkverträge mehr geben
die gewerkschaften fürchten trotzdem
dass sich die unternehmer neue
schlupflöcher suchen werden
thomas münten auslöser des neuen
gesetzes waren die zustände beim größten
deutschen fleischproduzenten tönnies in
rheda wiedenbrück bei dem sich im sommer
mehr als 1000 menschen die für
osteuropäische subunternehmen in der
schlachtung arbeiten mit dem corona
virus infiziert hatten
sowohl die arbeits als auch die
lebensbedingungen der arbeitenden werden
seit jahren von den gewerkschaften
kritisiert jetzt kommt es allerdings
darauf an dass mit wirksamen kontrollen
mit scharfen maßnahmen die wirksamkeit
dieses gesetzes durch durchgesetzt wird
und diese industrie ist bekannt dafür
dass sie jedes auch noch so kleine
schlupfloch in den gesetzen ausnutzt um
ihr ausbeuterische modell fortzusetzen
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
sagte heute bei der verabschiedung des
gesetzes im bundesrat zu hier genau auf
die künftigen lebensumstände zu achten
das sind auch menschen und nicht nur
menschen die hier irgendwie schuften
weil in deutschland sich zu wenig finden
das inzwischen zu tun sondern die
genauso ein recht darauf haben dass ihre
gesundheit schützen und das betrifft
auch die frage in welchen unterkünften
übernachten ob die hygienisch sind oder
ob das sammelunterkünfte im sinne von
gammel unterkünften sind die
fleischindustrie die bislang keine
direkte verantwortung für die meisten
beschäftigten tragen musste kritisiert
das neue gesetz als massiven eingriff in
die unternehmerische freiheit viele
arbeitsplätze seien in gefahr
zitat das verbot von jeglicher
leiharbeit ist unangemessen und ohne
grund ein abwandern der produktion ins
ausland wird die folge sein
vor der kamera wollten sich führende
fleisch hersteller heute nicht äußern
und jetzt in der sendung zu einem thema
das nach wie vor drängt aber durch
corona in den hintergrund gerät die
flucht richtung europa und da geraten
die kanarischen inseln immer mehr in den
blickpunkt in diesem jahr sind dort bis
mitte november etwa 17.000 migranten
angekommen sechsmal mehr als letztes
jahr
die flüchtlinge starten in offenen boten
von westafrika aus und was folgt ist
eine hunderte kilometer lange
gefährliche fahrt über den atlantik aus
dem senegal berichtet tim kröger
die kleine ninja ist erst vor wenigen
tagen zur welt gekommen ihren vater aber
wird sie nie kennen lernen denn er ist
vor einigen wochen beim versuch
gestorben mit dem boot auf der so
genannten atlantik route die kanarischen
inseln also europa zu erreichen
er wollte einfach gehen um seine
lebensbedingungen zu verbessern außerdem
bin ich krank und er wollte für mich
seine frau und seine kinder sorgen sehen
egal westafrika ein ausgangspunkt für
die atlantic route hunderte sind in
diesem jahr bereits gestorben zehn mal
mehr als 2009 10 haben die flucht gewagt
ein grund für den massiven anstieg ist
unter anderem auch die combat pandemie
die wirtschaft leidet und mit ihr die
menschen jobs gehen verloren löhne
sinken
touristen bleiben aus fluchtrouten über
libyen und das mittelmeer sind und
durchlässiger geworden auch fischer
brechen über den atlantik nach europa
auf bei große trawler aus ländern wie
china aber auch aus der eu die fische
wegfangen sagen sie das leben der
familien ist hart und es gibt kaum
hoffnung
wir haben vor allem von der fischerei
gelebt so unsere häuser gebaut unsere
probleme gelöst unsere kinder die zur
schule geschafft
oft ist es der druck der eigenen
familien sie zu unterstützen der die
meist jungen männer aufbrechen lässt
aber auch falsche vorstellungen von
europa sagen experten
viele junge menschen glauben dass europa
wegen der hohen todeszahlen im
zusammenhang mit coop 19 mehr menschen
sich um genügend arbeitskräfte zu haben
die menschen wissen um die gefahren aber
für ein besseres leben das kehren viele
alles
und so ist das in dieser
nachrichtensendung jetzt einen schritt
und kommen rüber zum sport und einem
alten bekannten und ich meinen gar nicht
ich höre noch nicht alt es gibt
neuigkeiten aus gelsenkirchen auf
schalke übernimmt zum vierten mal ein
alter bekannter das kommando huub
stevens soll die königsblauen mit einer
rosskur auf kurs bringen trainer manuel
baum wurde nach nur zehn spielen
entlassen der tabellenletzte wartet seit
mitte januar auf einen bundesligasieg
mal abgesehen von dem mund nasenschutz
kommt einem dieses bild mehr als
vertraut vor irgendwie ist es so als
hätten sie auf schalke die zeit
zurückgedreht
ja die null muss stehen könnt ihr das
wieder schreiben habt ihr habt ihr
wieder etwas beschreiben die null muss
stehen intensive einzelgespräche will
stevens mit den verunsicherten spielern
führen viel zeit bleibt ihm nicht schon
morgen geht es gegen bielefeld große
taktische veränderungen sind nicht zu
erwarten
ich denke dass die köpfe frei bekommen
müssen und dass sie wieder freude und
spaß in das fußball erleben und dann
braucht man auch ein erfolgserlebnis bis
zum pokalspiel in ulm am dienstag soll
stevens amtszeit dieses mal nur dauern
borussia dortmunds neuer coach edin
terzic peilt heute live im zdf den
zweiten sieg im zweiten spiel an béla
réthy in berlin der erste fc union hat
allerdings sehr positive erinnerungen
ans duell im vergangenen jahr in der tat
ihm der aufstieg so war das der erste
sieg der bundesliga-geschichte 1 3 zu 1
gegen dortmund damals war das eine große
überraschung
inzwischen zeigt ihr union das ist
verbringt ganz groß und keinen respekt
hat man hat ja beinahe gegen bayern
münchen gewonnen sind gespannt heute auf
den auftritt mit dem neuen trainer mit
der intercity er nach seinem ersten
erfolg in bremen nach der entlassung von
lucien favre und jungen und dortmund sid
der tabellennachbarn dort nun vierter
und sechster ein offenes ein spannendes
spiel und bis in der um 20.15 wieder da
für sie in der alten försterei
dank béla réthy bis später thierry
laptop ist gewinnerin des biathlon
sprint in hochfilzen drei norwegerinnen
dem siegertreppchen genau wie gestern
ihre männlichen kollegen
franziska preuß bieten bleibt im
liegenden anschlag fehlerfrei eine
strafrunde nach dem stehendschießen
beschert ihr dann aber nur rang vier
eine halbe sekunde fehlt schließlich zum
dritten platz
janina hettich wird dreizehnte keine
glückszahl geht in diesem fall ich
herzlichen dank norbert für die menschen
in new york geht 2020 ein jahr der
extreme zumindest mit einer ordentlichen
portion schöne weiße weihnachtszeit zu
ende
der größte wintersturm seit jahren hat
manhattan in eine riesige spielfläche
für alle verwandelt schlittenfahren auf
den kleinen hügeln im central park oder
1 x time square auf langlaufskiern mal
sonne mal nebel meist mild das ist die
kurzfassung des wetters bei uns
ausführlicher hat das gleich katja
horneffer die kollegin marietta slomka
im heute journal gegen viertel nach neun
von uns allen hier danke für ihr großes
interesse am wochenende freut sich petra
gerster auf sie wir sehen uns dann
montag wieder in allen einen sehr
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren der regen
ist aus deutschland abgezogen aber was
übrig geblieben ist ist die feuchte luft
und deswegen lösen sich die nebelfelder
nicht überall auf zb am bodensee an der
donau aber auch hier im mittelrheintal
da blieb es den ganzen tag über trieb
viele von ihnen hatten aber auch einfach
nur strahlenden sonnenschein und so gibt
es auch in der nacht zum teil klaren
sternenhimmel die nebelfelder breiten
sich wieder aus und die temperaturen
sinken am niederrhein bis 7 grad kälter
wird sind lieder und den oberbayern bei
minus 1 bis minus 4 grad und morgen
bleibt es auch wieder in den
nebelgebieten am kältesten mit nur so
ein bis fünf grad sonst wird es sehr
mild am mildesten wieder am niederrhein
mit 14 grad
das wetter ist ganz ähnlich wie heute
mal geht's dichte nebelfelder mal
scheint auch die sonne nachmittags
kommen dann von westen her dichtere
wolken an
bei einem winter meist nur leicht bis
mäßig aus südlichen richtungen weht am
vierten advent überquert uns dann regen
und danach wird es stürmisch an der
nordsee und richtig will dann am
dienstag mit bis zu 16 grad wie sie aber
hier am trend für freiburg im breisgau
sehen können könnte es tatsächlich genau
pünktlich zu weihnachten deutlich kälter
werden und dann gibt es vielleicht sogar
schnee im flachland schönen abend noch